uh today i am welcoming to the program
barbara friese who's an environmental
attorney
energy analyst and author of the
recently released book
industrial strength denial eight stories
of corporations defending
the indefensible from the slave trade to
climate change
barbara it's great to have you on today
thanks for having me david
so this is this is a theme this idea of
denial it's a strategy really
and uh whenever there is a disagreement
in culture in politics wherever uh
sometimes the facts are debated but
sometimes
you see a strategy of of simply simply
denying the fact
saying those are not the facts or i
don't believe what you were presenting
me
a sort of an equivalent to bearing one's
head
in the sand as it may be how far back
does the sort of grift of denial go as
you've charted and researched it
well i went back as far as the slave
trade
and a challenge to it in britain in the
late 1700s and early 1800s
i do think of this as a part of human
psychology so i think it goes back as
long as
as we've been humans but as as far as a
documented
industry campaign of denial we know that
it's at least
as old as the slave trade and what were
the arguments made around the slave
trade
they were appalling and absurd they
basically
embraced this kind of rescue narrative
that
they were not uh you know enslaving
people they weren't taking captives from
africa
and putting them on horrible plantations
on the contrary they were rescuing them
from a worse fate in africa where they
would have been
put to death as prisoners of war or
eaten by cannibals
and delivering them to you know first of
all on a lovely festive slave ship
to a very comfortable plantation where
they would be
well treated and have comfortable homes
and be taken care of
in in old age and sickness and
it was it was really appalling and
because this was the british trade and
the british dominated the trade um
they were speaking to an audience that
had no direct experience at all
of slavery so they could really get away
with with some whoppers that they
couldn't have gotten away with in the
united states where
people at least saw something of slavery
i've even heard
in the last few years that typically
from folks from certain political
persuasions in the united states
i'm not for slavery but conditions for
some
freed slaves were worse than with
certain slave owners which seems sort of
like a similar idea
well and in fact that was a strategy
that the british slave traders used they
frequently compared the conditions that
slaves lived under
with the poor in britain and of course
the poor in britain
did live under terrible conditions um so
it was sort of an example of
sort of this downward ratchet that that
as long as there were bad conditions for
one group you could use that as an
excuse
to allow even worse conditions for
another group
very present right now when we talk
about denial is is climate climate
science and climate science denial
and you you write about this in the book
i've been covering it
for a very long time is there something
unique to climate science denial maybe
either from a psychological perspective
or in some way that distinguishes it
from the other
denial grifts that you've covered or is
it just another version
of the same sort of thing well pretty
much
all the climate denial denials
that we see have appeared in other
industries over the decades and
centuries but
there are some things about climate
denial that i think make it just
particularly
easy one of them is that it is such a
huge problem
it is such a long-term problem it is
something that
everybody contributes to at least a
little bit in terms of
consuming fossil fuels and that's such a
familiar thing that our minds are not
really
triggered to be afraid of of things that
are that familiar
um and another thing i think that that
makes this unusual
is just the phenomenal success of
climate denial i mean you never heard
presidents of the united states at least
in the modern era
denying that tobacco caused cancer
but you have heard at least one of them
calling climate change a hoax
yeah that that's interesting because
some of the same people one of the
phenomena that i find interesting about
the climate
perspective climate issue is we know
what the science is and we know it's
overwhelming and at this point it's like
almost a cliche
to repeat it time and time again but the
people that deny it
seem to accept uncritically
the claims of some small sliver of
scientists they can find
or they in other words they seem to not
apply the same
critiques to those that happen to share
their
pre-existing notion and i've not found a
good way to break through
that kind of epistemological barrier
when i talk to those people
right one of the things i write about in
the book is basically tribalism and its
effect on the mind and how easily
triggered it is
and then how incredibly powerful it is
so in times of uncertainty
in times of conflict it becomes
particularly strong
and certainly the the level of
skepticism
you would apply to people outside your
tribe
becomes very very high and the level of
skepticism you
apply to those within your tribe telling
you what you want to hear
is very very low it's also a sort of
exaggerated confirmation bias that we
all indulge in personally
but that gets amplified in times like
this when the issue is this big
and when the industry in question
is really you know one of the most or
maybe the most powerful industry in the
world
and where you're talking about harms
that are really inherent
in its central product in that sense
it's kind of like tobacco
um and you know interestingly the the
big oil companies now just like big
tobacco
don't deny anymore the fundamental facts
of their product causing
harm and yet they have been denying it
for so many decades and put in place so
many barriers to regulation
uh that they're still benefiting from
the decades of denial past
what seems to be effective in getting
through the denial i mean i'm thinking
of
you know with coronavirus as an example
initially when there were some cases in
china it was very easy to just say it
won't come here and then it did and it's
very easy to say there won't be a lot of
cases and they'll go away and then
there's lots of cases but you say well
we're not going to have a lot of deaths
and then there's deaths and then people
will say
listen i'm hearing that people are dying
but i'm not seeing the bodies and then
you see the
news video of the mass graves being dug
and the refrigerated trucks and people
say
that's optics produced to trick people
for political reasons like there
there's always that ability to say
it's stage managed it's fake whatever
what is effective at getting
past all of that
i wish i could give you a formula that
that made it clear what's effective
it does seem to matter to have facts and
to have
imagery and to bring that before the
public
what tends to be most effective in
overcoming denial
is for there to no longer be any real
credible benefit
to denial so for example that's i think
what brought the tobacco industry
finally
into you know the modern era because
it was to the point where nobody
believed them anyway and they were being
sued for fraud and they had all kinds of
other
problems and they realized that
admitting that their product killed
people wasn't really going to prevent
them from selling it even after decades
of saying if this was true we'd stop
selling it
so that tends to be what happens i i'd
like to imagine that eventually
when it comes to larger efforts to
overcome denial
if if you think of us as being very
tribal and and taking on kind of a herd
mentality then perhaps when people who
are at
the head of the herd switch uh it might
lead to some
some greater acceptance you might look
at
the the george floyd protests which
isn't really the same thing but
but you had the video of his killing
right and i think that helped a lot of
members of the public
who had no financial or ideological
stake in this one way or another but
except that they wanted to believe the
world was you know better than it is
when they saw that i think a certain
amount of public denial
about just how bad things could be went
away
so i i do tend to be a big believer in
evidence
and trying to bring that out there even
though we do have a lot of examples of
it failing to convince people
how much of a problem do you see uh the
corporate media coverage of some of
these issues being and this
the example i'm thinking of is although
the science on climate
is you know 99.98 to 0.02 or however
lopsided it is you you want to um claim
it is it's somewhere in that range
you have numerous and regular corporate
media debates
where you have two people and they're
given equal time
and one person 50 of the debate
represents the 99.98 and 50
of the debate meaning one person
represents the point zero two
it's this sort of false balance problem
which i think corporate media
engages in in order to be uh
neutral as they say but neutral is not
objective and so i'm wondering how much
you think
that contributes to some of this denial
and provides cover
yeah i think that has always been a
problem when it comes to
particularly climate change i mean even
if you were to try to do it in some more
balanced way and for example you were to
have a
a debate with 99 climate scientists who
recognized the threat and
one who denied it um i think that the
audience would still come away saying oh
well then there are two different
opinions
so i i think you're right that pretty
much any attention to
what is now a a very much discredited
viewpoint
gives it more credibility with the
public and particularly with the public
that is
not scientific and not fully aware of
all the data because you can never
really convey all the data or or the
strength of it to
a non-scientific public when it comes to
something like
coal which relates to the climate um
a debate more generally in that
certainly you know if you disbelieve the
science on climate
you might be more supportive of coal
because of its immediate
sort of monetary benefits in that it's
cheap and we don't need
new infrastructure like we would with
solar or wind or whatever the case may
be
how have you seen or sort of observed
the coal debate happened during the
current administration where we've seen
the president
essentially say that he wants to take
take this
out of the market the free market of
course pointing to letting coal die
to revitalize an industry that from a
climate perspective doesn't make sense
where does this fit into the discussion
in terms of people who
who say yeah we should we really should
bring coal back is it a denial
of the climate science is it a sort of
political or tribal based reaction
some combination of the two yeah i think
it's it's certainly a combination of the
two and it's certainly a reflection of
the fact
that um to the extent the coal industry
has been defending itself in the past by
saying that you should let the market
decide
that sort of ideological justification
for burning coal
really wasn't what was ever motivating
them and
in fact what the president has tried to
do is to get uh
power companies to buy coal and and
subsidize coal
even when they would prefer not to so so
that was
a pretty clear uh illustration that
the ideological justification was never
really what was driving it
the last thing i want to touch a touch
on is i i think if we didn't mention
this we would be missing a huge piece of
this which is the denial side is often
very well funded
and when you think back to tobacco and i
forget if what if it was the clean
skies or clean air initiative or
whatever which was basically about
convincing restaurant owners hey if you
want freedom from regulation
we need you on board so that people will
be allowed to smoke inside your
restaurants when the movement for no
smoking and restaurants started
these are really well-funded movements
and that seems to dramatically uh
skew a lot of the conversations that are
happening does it not
oh sure i mean the industries that i
wrote about and i focus just on eight
industries and and most of the really
big ones
they had an enormous amount of money uh
to promote their viewpoint
to give to other sort of free-market
um ideological groups to promote their
views more secretly
to hire people to to write articles but
not to explain where they got the money
and then ultimately you end up with an
entire industry
that supports other industries that are
trying to be
trying to deny the science so you've got
the
the law firms the pr firms the
advertising agencies
and the so-called non-profits that that
become advocates
uh to oppose regulation so i mean i
i try to write about this partly from a
kind of psychological perspective
looking at the social science and i
think what happens is that
for the the individuals in the
corporations that confront
these charges that there is a very
natural
instinctive inclination to deny it which
is
just part of human nature i think it
then moves pretty quickly into a
corporate strategy
and then it moves from there into its
own kind of a denial industry with the
same
pr firms and others appearing again and
again and then i think it moves into an
ideology
and and so it's that progression that
makes
denial uh this very human thing
but but promoted by these very powerful
institutions
such a destructive thing do you have any
insights
into the psychology of the in the cogs
in the wheels so to speak
that are carrying out a lot of these
these denial campaigns because i could
imagine a situation where
the people working at the pr firm or the
people working at a corporation or the
law firm
at the individual level many of them
probably know that what they're doing is
lying and that they're denying
what what are the facts is it as simple
as listen i'm a cog in the wheel
i'm just trying to put food on the table
and this is going to happen
regardless or have you had any insights
into that
at the individual level i think that is
definitely part of it
um and corporations themselves
especially the big ones
are designed to make the individual not
feel responsible for what the
corporation does it does that through
division of labor you're just a cog in a
wheel and and we know for sure that
diminishes your imp your
feelings of responsibility for the
consequences
you've got management divided from
ownership
you've got this ideology that tells
managers that their only responsibility
is to maximize shareholder pressure
shareholder profit meanwhile
shareholders don't feel responsible
because they're far away it's
transactional they may just own the
stock for a little while and
they don't know what's going on anyway
uh we also know that
power tends to focus the mind on your
most salient
goals which if you're a corporate
executive is profit
it also there's some evidence seems to
reduce your
risk awareness and your risk perception
once you become aware of it and your
general
social responsibility again there's the
tribalism the competitiveness inherent
in incorporations the market mindset
so yeah there's there are a lot of
psychological things you could point to
in fact i
suggest in the book that if you are a
super villain trying to get the world to
destroy itself
by taking crazy risks um you might just
create a society very much like our
corporate dominated market society
because there are many many things there
that undermine our innate sense
of social responsibility very well said
the book
is industrial strength denial eight
stories of corporations defending the
indefensible from the slave trade to
climate change we've been speaking with
the book's author barbara freeze
barbara thank you so much for your time
today thank you david i appreciate it